each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so since we're running a little
late after Victor's talk we'll have just
a very short break before Francois
Moran's talk so now I'm very pleased to
introduce Victor Miller from Center for
communications research he's one of the
two Co inventors of elliptic curve
cryptography and he'll speak to us on
elliptic curves cryptography and
computation okay Thank You Kristin and
all the organizers really pleased to be
here it's hard to believe it's 25 years
anyway so this is a sort of a personal
story about my own Odyssey with with
this and some of my own background but I
I couldn't resist even though I hope I
don't get into copyright trouble this
this I thought was was was one of my
favorite cartoons in The New Yorker and
this is sort of an an indication of
always you know oh he's always pushing
on to the limits but my my own
background is is as a number theorist
and I think it's it's appropriate in
many ways especially for me I mean Serge
Lang was my mathematical mentor as an
undergraduate and in fact I realize now
that when I was a freshman in college I
took a course in him which could be
described as freshman mathematics for
prospective PhDs and in the second week
he gave us all an assignment which I now
recognize was one of the key lemons that
Tate used in his proof of the existence
of the quadrant a quadrant isset ii of
the neurone Tate height but of course he
he didn't mention elliptic curves at all
but but but they were always there in
the background and and for anyone who
who knew Serge or heard of them
this quote is very appropriate it's
possible to write endlessly about
elliptic curves this is not a threat and
given that lying published something
like 60 books this is this is not an
idle threat either
anyway but a large part of the motor
nation of well most number theorists I
certainly can't speak for all are really
solutions of daya Fenton equations
I mean basically we're we're all of you
know sometimes you take very long
detours but basically a lot of the
original motivating problems are you
have a particular Diophantus equation
and you want to find the solutions or
find all the solutions or describe them
or something and of course the most
infamous example is is Fermat's Last
Theorem which you know Andrew Weil said
you know was his sort of you know his
his motivation you know four years in in
studying number theory and and there's
another thing I mean which which
professor Frey touched on is that it's
it's sort of very interesting what
happened to qualitative number theory in
the nineteenth century up through the
beginning of the 20th century the sort
of prime piece of of number theory at
least was really caught up with
computation I mean it really wasn't
enough for people to just show that
solutions existed you really had to find
them or at least make it make a decent
attempt to find them but I think what
happened and this is pure speculation on
my part is is as the problems got harder
and harder and beyond the realm of human
computation people started you know
concentrating on sort of more you know
generally existential things but I think
the idea of explicitly computing these
things was always in the back of the
mind of everybody and even if it was
suppressed I know professor birch told
me many years ago that that you would be
surprised to see some of the people who
really were computers in secret for
example I I think I think that he
mentioned that Andre they did a lot of
explicit computation in secret but then
carefully suppress it in his papers or
maybe it was a molarity well he it it it
might have been but but it but for
whatever sociological reason this
happened I think what happened is that
when computing machines came into being
this actually made some of these
computations which were clearly seem to
be impossible
conceivable and I think people got back
to thinking about the kind of motivation
that people had in the 19th century
because now it was actually possible to
do it I mean as a sideline you can look
at the whole field that's been generated
you know with grosvenor bases
computations I mean basically you know
this would have thrilled a lot of the
people who worked in invariance in the
19th century because now it's actually
possible to compute make some of these
horrendously hard computations which
were clearly beyond any any hand hand
capacity so and and as I said if for
elliptic curves well these these slides
were originally they but but elliptic
curves were until about maybe 25 or 30
years ago if if one looked at actually
absolute numbers of people who looked at
it a relatively arcane field you know I
was a graduate student at Harvard which
was one of the Centers of this and it
was easy to lose perspective when you
were surrounded by by some of the
world's experts but when you realize
that that was actually a significant
percentage of all the people in the
world who really knew you know anything
serious about the field and as I said
well in any case before 1985 it was
virtually unheard of in the in the
crypto and theoretical computer science
community there were maybe like one or
two people you know who worked didn't
study as number theorists who may have
may have heard of it and and and and I
said I just made a count this is
certainly a vague think so
mathematical reviews up tool up to 1984
if I looked for papers or articles or
books with elliptic curve in the title
there were only about 200 and and now
they're well actually I should update
this now there there were at least 2000
so it's very clear that that there's
been a lot more now now part of it has
been been number theoretic and part of
it has just been the fact that all and
I'll test it the fact that elliptic
curve cryptography and other things came
into being is obviously motivated a lot
of people who sort of you know came in
from from outside of number theory and a
lot of you know engineering work which
is good work but
but but now things are not so obscure
and I just did a Google search for the
phrase elliptic curve cryptography and
admittedly a lot of them are redundant
but it yielded 83 pages of hits so
that's that's quite quite a lot
well here's Carl virus Russ whom was
mentioned and basically so elliptic
curves as professor Frey said with with
in in a simple-minded way you could
think of just the set of solutions to
this equation y squared equals x cube
plus ax plus B which is usually called a
short virus cross equation and in
general any sort of cubic curve as long
as it doesn't have you know
singularities is is such such a curve
and as long as you actually have a point
you can put it in in virus dress form
and as this point pointed out and and
also the set has a natural geometric
group law which respects the field of
definition and that's important it means
if you take two points and you add them
and their coordinates are in a
particular field then so is there some
and the virus trust where where virus
stress gets in the act there is he
actually came up with what's called the
virus stress p function in which
virtually everybody who takes of course
in complex analysis learns about and my
one of my favorite professors Lippmann
Bears used to say it's not very hard the
hardest thing about the virus stress p
function is actually writing the virus
draws P but but and and it's the only
doubly periodic complex function so at
any time you give a talk and elliptic
curves it seems to be mandatory to put
up a picture that some somehow resembles
this there are many variants on it and
you can see if you have P and Q that you
you have a third point of intersections
it's a cubic curve which we call P star
Q and then you reflect it through some
other point and you get the sum in fact
that was an anyway so here's Niels
Henrik Henrik Abel which who basically
studied his study were the periods
certain integrals of algebraic functions
and basically he studied what today well
of course there are called abelian
varieties which are sort of multi den
multi dimensional generalization of
elliptic curves when you get to higher
when G is bigger than one when there are
more than two periods things get a
little more complicated you have to talk
about things called polarizations and
riemann forms and whatnot but i won't i
won't talk about that here because
elliptic curves are are complicated
enough so and abelian varieties also
have a group law and in fact the
interesting thing is their group is
commutative otherwise known as abelian
groups but it but it's sort of a
coincidence that they're what well it
was named they were both named after him
but but but but it's a coincidence that
there were two things named after him
that just happened to coincide and
elliptic curves over the rational
numbers that was again pointed out by
professor Frey is the set of solutions
always forms a finitely generated group
well set of solutions over a number
field or over more generally what's
called a global field and there's even a
procedure and I use that actually in the
technical terms and computation to find
generators and very often it's quite
efficient it's known descent but it in
fact it's not even known to terminate in
many cases the termination of this
procedure in some ways is is actually
measured by part of the Tait Schaffer
average group which was mentioned by
professor Frey and in particular if the
Tait Schaffer average group is finite or
at least a certain local part of the
group is finite then in fact this
procedure will will terminate but it's
not known in all cases and as I said
there's as as was mentioned there's a
size function which is called the vey
height which is the logarithm of the
maximum of the numerator and denominator
which roughly measures the number of
bits in a point in other words if you
were to actually write down these points
in ordinary ways as
with with rational numbers and think of
how many bits which you need to write
down the numerator denominators that
would be roughly measured you know up to
maybe a a constant factor by this VAE
height and there's something which was
also mentioned called the Tate height
which could be considered sort of the
smoothing of the very height and the
Tate height has much nicer mathematical
properties in that it's a non degenerate
quadratic positive definite quadratic
form as was also mentioned and the so
the points also his professor for I
mentioned if you tensor the set of
points with the reals this actually
sticks them inside a real vector space
and the points on the elliptic curve
actually form a lattice and your four
people in case they haven't seen her are
Louis Modell and Andre vay and I will
say that I actually saw professor Modell
once just a few years before he died
when he spoke at Harvard and someone
asked him about the more delve a theorem
and he actually seemed to take a little
umbrage about that and said he never
wrote anything with professor day in his
life
Wardell originally proved his theorem in
about 1922 I think or 1920 there abouts
over the over the rationals Andre vay
basically was assigned the
generalization of this as his thesis
topic actually he was assigned much more
and this is what he proved in his thesis
in the late 1920s and in a sense this
actually this problem motivated him for
a large part of the rest of his career
because he was very dissatisfied with
the foundations of algebraic and
arithmetic geometry which he encountered
in doing this so in fact this actually
caused him to you know we write about 25
years later when he came out with his
foundations of algebraic geometry which
was the be all and end all before growth
and he came along and here was my my
graduate advisor Barry Mazur who proved
among other things as was as was alluded
to that a
folklore conjecture that no point on an
elliptic curve over the rationals has
order more than twelve I mean more
specifically since professor fry
mentioned the modular curves he he
basically showed that professor fry
mentioned that the modular curve X 1 of
n parameterize --is pairs of elliptic
curves and points of order n and there
was a folklore conjecture that people
had noticed that there were only a
finite list of n for which X 1 of n had
genus 0 that is could have a possible
infinite number of points and so the
folkloric conjecture was those were
exactly the N for which there was a
point of order and on an elliptic curve
and that was what what Mazur proved and
here here's John Tate well to two
pictures the first one was in 1969 taken
at a conference at Oxford there was a
very large group picture which had a lot
of the pictures of a lot of the players
there and here's he was Dante today
who's still quite active and and working
on things and so as was mentioned in the
beginning I mean in in the history of
computing computing around elliptic
curves has been there from almost the
beginning so in 1952 amyl Artin on the
Left asked john von neumann to do a
calculation on the exact computer which
i think was at los alamos about cubic
Gauss ohms related to the distribution
of the number of points Y squared is x
q+ o and ENIAC oh and not exact yeah
sorry about that okay yes thank you yes
he was the any idea the exact computer
was the one that Brian PERTs used on the
ENIAC computer about cubic as sums and
so I mean basically people were were
thinking about elliptic curves and
computation from well I mean from long
before that but as soon as computers
came along it seemed to be the the prime
thing and I mean one of the problems
with this is there is sort of a a
problem with the misleading law of small
numbers that before you could compute
these things you could
compute essentially the each of these
gal sums involved have absolute values
square root of P and there was a
question about how the angles were
distributed which could be considered a
a forerunner of one of the questions
that Professor Frey was talking about
you know which which related to the Sato
Tait conjecture even though this is has
a cm curve so it's not the the usual
case and the problem is I think that it
was just too difficult to compute many
examples by hand and it wasn't clear how
indicative the the data were so so art
and wanted more data to look at and here
are our Brian birch and Peter Swigert
and I are back at the 1969 conference
and as was mentioned they formulated
their important conjecture only after
extensive computer calculations and so
then and now and here here here they are
now well of course you can see professor
birch right here and and and actually as
a sideline there they're sort of two
quotes Carl Ludwig's Eagle said in one
of his letters I think two more Dell the
phrase at number theory is a beautiful
garden and Hendrik Lenstra in a talk
back around the year 2000 I would say
said that oil was discovered in the
garden so so in fact here here were the
here with the drillers so in 1976 Diffie
and Hellman proposed the first public
key crota call and so said let P is a
large prime and the non-zero elements of
a finite field FP form a cyclic group
this is sort of an old theorem and
number theory that when you study when
you take a first course in number theory
this is one of the first things that you
or one of the early things that you
prove is the theorem of the primitive
root and the security of their idea
depends on the difficulty of solving the
following problem if I given you P and G
which is some primitive root
and G to the a and G to the B find G to
the a B and that's known as the the D H
P or diffie-hellman problem and Diffie
and Hellman speculated in their paper
that the only way they could think well
there was an obvious way of solving it
is they could reduce it to the problem
of solving what's the discrete log or or
sometimes known as the index problem so
given the primitive root G and G to the
a find a of course it's not immediately
obvious there might not be another
method of doing that but I'll comment on
that later and soon this was generalized
to work over any finite field especially
over f2 to the N f2 to the end was very
popular because people in coding theory
used those sort of fields as their bread
and butter and there are in fact where
lots of hardware and circuits and
whatnot already built to do fast
computation and those things so it
seemed to make sense to use them and
here we're Marty Hellman and with Diffie
back in around the time when they
invented it and here they are today
actually what hasn't changed that much
Marty's sort of Marty sort of looks like
a banker now so here is the idea so the
attacks on under sweet logarithm problem
first Hellman and one of his PhD student
Stephen Pollard published a paper about
a year or two later which among other
things notice that you only need to
solve the problem in a cyclic group of
prime order that basically if you had
group extensions that you only needed to
solve the the problem in each of the
pieces and then it was easy to put them
back together and so basically in the
original problem the security depends on
the largest prime divisor Q of P minus 1
or if you're working in a field f2 to
the end know of 2 to the n minus 1 and
it was also known by a procedure of Dan
shanks dubbed the baby step giant step
method that you could always solve this
problem in general in time Big O of
square root of Q and they speculated
that this was the best that you could do
so
in some sense they were right and in
some sense they were wrong oh I'll get
to that later because it turns out
unknown to them because a lot of things
in number theory are somewhat obscure to
the outside community
ayyyy Western and JC P Miller in 1965
published a book called a table of
indices and primitive roots and in the
appendix of the book they outlined a
procedure for actually finding solving
the what would be called the discrete
logarithm problem for large you know
when when you had large prime fields
which would be better than this sort of
square root of P method I will say that
they outlined the procedure and they
didn't analyze it precisely in in in the
current way that people think about
analyzing complexity but and in fact it
was so obscure that that Len Adleman
was unaware of it and he independently
rediscovered the idea in about 1978 and
published a paper where here he actually
did analyze it fairly precisely and he
needed some heuristics but basically the
running time was Big O of X both square
root of two log P log log P and in fact
what happened is after Adelman paper
Hellman and another one of his
colleagues
Ranieri saw that you could do a similar
thing when you're working in discrete
logs of f2 to the N and in fact so so
this is where this sort of hit me I was
working at IBM Research at the time and
there was a paper by fujihara Blake
Mullen and Vanstone well at least one of
them is here Scott and they gave a
significant speed up at a helmet and
rainy airy paper and and this well first
of all here was Dan shanks and here's
Len Adleman not here and basically I
would say at the time I've I've been a
friend of Don Cochran Smith since
graduate school and and have been a
colleague of his first at IBM and now
now where I work now at CCR and in 1983
fujihara came to IBM and gave a talk on
on the paper that I just mentioned with
a very picturesque title how to rob
the reason for this title was that the
discrete logarithm system was you know
and they diffie-hellman system was so
attractive that the Federal Reserve Bank
of California had decided to use the a
system based on on the difficulty of
discrete logarithm to secure their
financial transactions and they were
going to use it over the field F 2 to
the 127 2 to the 127 was attractive
because 2 to the 127 minus 1 is a
Mersenne prime so in fact the divisor of
the of the multiplicative size of the
multiplicative group was as big as it
possibly could be and not only that
youlet packard was very obligingly
manufacturing some hardware to do very
fast arithmetic in that field you know
for that use and they of course we're
going to sell it to other people you
know as a good crypto system
and so fujihara stock peak Don's
interest well here's here's Don
coppersmith for those people who don't
know him
and here is fujihara Blake Mullen and
Vanstone and basically the idea is
related to a problem of sub exponential
time factoring of integers I mean
professor fry mentioned that smooth
numbers and this is this is sort of a
very key player in this so this first
idea came about I mean some some people
may dispute the history whether this was
the first there was a program called C
frac standing for continued fraction in
a paper by Morrison and brillhart and
brillhart coined the term factor base
and basically this was a method using
continued fraction expansion of
quadratic rationalities I won't get into
this to sort of come up with heuristic
aliy good sets of numbers which could be
used in this sort of general procedure
for factor base which I'll outline than
sense enriched repeal of sitting right
there has something called the linear
sieve I think you store
Callay Maurice crachek back in the 1930s
or 1920s actually had some ideas like
this but it wasn't clear how far he
could go because there really weren't
any decent computing machines at the
time so you had to do all this by hand
or you know if you were D H lamer you
know you would build your own machines
but and Carl Pomerance
coined the term smooth and the quadratic
sieve and actually I got a dispute from
Oriya and Lester about this and the
notation which it called L functions I
mean this is the one thing I find very
confusing because for a number theorist
cell functions means a particular thing
which is already mentioned and the
people who are sort of in this field
then used this other thing and they
talked about L functions there and this
is endlessly causing me confusion when
people are talking about L functions and
I have to remember what context they're
using it but in any case why why they
used L I don't know but the notation was
come up I think Hendrik Lenstra came up
with an earlier version of this notation
with without the first parameter a but
basically the notation L sub X of a
semicolon B is just exponential of B log
X to the a log log X to the one minus a
and the interesting thing about this
function is this sort of interpolates
between exponential running time and
polynomial running time when the first
parameter a is one you have fully
exponential and when it's zero you have
polynomial and which is sort of the holy
grail and basically what happened is
that the original factor base at least
while URIs --tx got a equal to 1/2 and
so basically where this function really
ends up coming coming into play is
there's been a lot of analyzing the
probability that random integer factors
into small Prime's and this actually was
a series of papers going back probably
from from the 1930s or 1940s up to the
present it done a lot more impetus when
suddenly it had a real you know killer
application so to speak but and
here's John brillhart at the same
conference at Oxford and here's rich
repeal who's sitting right there in fact
and here's Carl Pomerance who also was
in graduate school with me so basically
after fujihara stalk Don started
thinking seriously about the sweet log
problem and we basically would talk
about this a few times a week and he
sort of taught me a lot about his
insights and the intricacies the index
calculus index calculus it was a term
coined by Andrew at Lascaux to describe
all family of algorithms so this
algorithm was still an L of 1/2
algorithm but it it had a better
constant than the original algorithm
constant is good because the constant
was in the exponential factor but the
whole idea is Don figured out an
algorithm which was L of 1/3 and this
made an immense difference and basically
fujihara x' estimate in his talk was
that after doing a pre computation in
those days of course the computers in
those days was sort of pitiful by by
today's standards in those days he he
estimated that it would take about a
nine-month pre-computation and then
they'd be able to solve individual
discrete logs in maybe about a day or
two after doing this pre-computation
Don's innovation basically changed the
pre-computation to about 40 minutes on
our current mainframe computer at IBM
and individual discrete logs were solved
in about 5 seconds so this effectively
torpedoed the actual system that that
the Federal Reserve Bank was going to
use and 10 years later basically based
on what in retrospect a very similar
ideas Dan Gordon devised an L of one
third algorithm which worked over over
the finite field of P elements and
here's Dan Gordon who now works at our
my West Coast branch and so there's a
question to work Helmut our Pollard
write about discrete logarithms so the
answer is yes and no so the original
problem as stated no
I mean I've already said that there are
these much better algorithms in these
square-root of algorithms and yet but
the point is is you needed to use some
specific property which was smoothness
to make the attacks work so turned out
that Igor Nechayev and then later
generalized by Viktor Shoop showed that
if you had a black box group so
basically a black box group is one in
which the elements of the group are just
as far as you can tell just random
bitstrings and you can ask a black box
saying tell me what the product of these
two elements are or you can ask you know
are these two equal or you know
calculate the inverse so in other words
basically this is sort of an abstract
version of saying that you're only using
the fact that it's a group and you're
not using anything very specific about
what the actual bits mean and basically
they showed that if you had such a group
that the best that you could possibly do
to solve a discrete logarithm problem
was time I should call that theta of
square root of Q so in other words you
you had to take at least square root of
Q time and in fact shoot generalize this
saying well suppose that you could use
randomness and you were only satisfied
with having a a positive fraction of the
answers you know in a certain amount of
time in other words you would compute a
certain amount of time and if you didn't
get the answer by then you just give up
he basically showed that it was still
square root of Q you really couldn't
couldn't do any better that there
weren't any positive fraction of lucky
points so to speak but what about
discrete the diffie-hellman problem
which really is the original problem so
Olli Mauer and and later Dan Boehner and
dick Lipton gave strong evidence that it
was no harder than the discrete
logarithm problem and basically to do
that they actually ended up using
elliptic curves in in a very interesting
way which I won't go into so here's
victor Shoop and here's Willie Mauer dan
Bonin and dick Lipton
so no idea so first of all my own
background was didn't graduate school
that that's what I worked on I worked on
elliptic curves and modular forms and so
I was sort of in a good position and
and and you know primed for this so to
speak so when I visited Android let's go
and Jeff ligarius at Bell Labs in August
83 they showed me a pre pinup of paper
by Renee scoff which which has already
been alluded to giving a polynomial time
algorithm for counting points and
elliptic curve over FP now of course
having a background looked occurs I
immediately appreciated this I will say
as a sidelight that it was difficult to
get the theoretical computer science
community to appreciate this stuff early
because this had been actually submitted
to the prestigious Fox conference and it
had been rejected
I know ligarius told me that he was on
the program committee and he was rather
upset about this but he couldn't you're
you're shaking your head Renee what
well okay all right well anyway anyway
this is what Jeff ligarius told me but
anyway but shortly thereafter I saw a
paper by Hendrik Lenstra who was Rene's
advisor or one of his advisers which
used elliptic curves to factor integers
in time L of 1/2 and again because I
already had a quite substantial
background and lift occurs I immediately
appreciated the ideas and so this
combined with Don's attack on discrete
log over f2 to the end got me thinking
of using elliptic curves to discrete
logarithm and and there's really a good
reason for that I mean not just because
I know about elliptic curves but well so
anyway here's Android let's go and Jeff
ligarius and here's Renee who's sitting
right there
and here's Hendrick Lenstra and sort of
the characteristic pose and so basically
at the time it wasn't new I mean many
people realize in the abstract that the
whole protocol only needed some sort of
gadget where you could do Associated
multiplication that was certainly not
new with me the real question is why
would you want to do it in any other
sort of group so when you start thinking
systematically you know and I said
finite fields mostly have index calculus
type attacks so what other kinds of
groups are so the good candidates are
things called algebraic groups and
algebraic groups without going into all
the definitions are roughly things where
the you can actually write down the
group law and calculate them by
calculating rational functions the
points in some in some vector space you
know which which have other properties
you know which usually satisfy some
series of equations and the idea is that
such a things are sort of inherently
relatively efficient to calculate
because calculating polynomials of a
small degree is pretty efficient and
then there's a general theorem in the
field by Claude Chevalley which
basically says without getting into the
you know technical points that algebraic
groups are extensions of matrix groups
by abelian varieties and so combined
with the the thing that poling and
Hellman know
since you have extension fields it means
that any discrete log that you would do
in any sort of algebraic group sort of
can be solved by either solving it you
know going down to some sort of matrix
group or going down to an abelian
variety and putting them together so in
some sense if you're in a matrix group
if you're in a sub subgroup of a matrix
group they've already been attacked by
finite field since basically you look at
the characteristic polynomial of
something and and basically what you
really are end up doing to find a
discrete log is you end up reducing it
to a discrete log in an extension field
of the of the finite field so in some
sense those have been taken care of I
mean one would have to analyze you know
exactly how much it's costing you to go
to the extension field so it seemed
obvious to analyze the idea in abelian
varieties and so and here's Claude
Chevalley and so here's the idea of the
index calculus without getting into all
the details so give it a primitive root
of a prime denote by you know X is log
sub G of a the the actual discrete log
the integer and 0 to P minus 1
satisfying G to the x equals a and you
choose a factor base or the first K
Prime so your K is some parameter which
you're going to choose later to optimize
things and the whole idea is that you do
a first a pre-processing step to find
the logarithms to the base G of each of
the things in the factor base and I'll
describe how to do that later and then
wants you to solve your original problem
you use the result of the table that
you've calculated in the first case to
actually find the answer to the general
case and here's how you do it so in the
pre-processing step you basically choose
a random Y and you calculate Z equals to
e to the Y now the nice thing about that
since you've chosen Y and you have Z you
already know the answer to the discrete
log of Z because you've you've chosen it
and so the whole idea is U then Z is is
a residue mod P but you just treat it as
an integer you do lifting and you
see if that lift factors into primes and
in F only you know what either does or
it doesn't if it does we have an
equation like that Z equals P 1 to the e
1 x PK to the e K and then you reduce
that equation mod P and you take logs
well the whole idea you know the log of
Z because you've generated it and you
know the e e ones you know know the
exponents and the only thing you don't
know are the unknowns of logs of G of P
one but that is a linear equation it's a
linear equation in Z mod P minus one so
the whole idea and solving linear
equations if you have enough linear
equations you know you know essentially
the same number of linear equations as
unknowns you can solve them and so the
whole idea is that you could just keep
doing this at random until you get
enough linear equations and then you
solve them and you know there's a lot of
details which I've swept under the rug
but the individual logs are very similar
so you choose a random Y and you look at
Z equals a times G to the Y a is the guy
that you're trying to take the log of
and you treat Z as an integer you do the
same thing and if it does you know you
if it factors like that then basically
you have an equation like that and you
notice that everything in that equation
is known except logs to G of a the
things on the right hand side are known
because that's what you've calculated in
the pre-processing step and so there's a
whole question is you know as I said if
it does you know so the question is how
likely is that to factor and that's
where the smooth numbers come in and so
basically you can sort of see eristic
Allah even though if not quantitatively
that the bigger K is the more likely you
are to factor that way and where the
whole this whole L function comes in is
this actually quantitatively measures
how likely it is to factor and but what
happens if you increase K your linear
system gets bigger and the bigger linear
system you have the more costly it is to
solve so there's there's a certain
trade-off on one side you know so
basically the whole idea is that once
you've actually quantitatively
here doubt how much it costs you then
has a slight optimization problem - to
find the optimal value of K to make the
trade-off on the two sides equal
and basically the optimal value once you
sort of plug in everything and you go
through everything you end up with Elsa
P of 1/2 C for some constant C the
standards see that you get a square root
of 2 there are other tricks that you can
use that get the constant C down to
slightly above 1 and the coppersmith and
Gordon methods can be thought of in in
in a very vague overview way of using a
very clever choice of probability in
other words instead of C over there
you've chosen Y completely at random so
they used an idea where it's possible in
some clever way to bias the choice of Y
so that you get your probability of
succeeding in that factorization up that
that again sweeps a lot of things under
the rug but that can be thought of as
what's going on and basically what
happens is that after they balance
everything they change the 1/2 there to
1/3 which is a very substantial change
so the natural thing is and I mean this
was the case 25 years ago and is still
the case today the best-known algorithms
for doing discrete logs over you know
finite fields over the multiplicative
group of finite fields are still based
on the idea of a factor base there's
something called the number field sieve
and there are various variants of it but
basically that's that's the best you can
seem to be able to do and so it seemed
natural to see what would happen if you
try to do the same sort of thing over
elliptic curves so the obvious thing to
do is to do exactly the same thing you
choose random points you multi you know
you buy by by taking a fixed point and
multiplying them by a random thing and
then lifting them but when you talk
about lifting them you immediately run
into a problem so basically also as
alluded to by Professor Frey because the
because the number
if you have E as an elliptic curve over
the rationals that because the the set
of solutions and the rationals is
finitely generated this you know
combined with the properties of the tape
you know narrow untied height this
actually shows that there's a very small
that the number of points of a given
height grows very very weakly you know
compared to what had happened what
happens in the multiplicative group you
know of the rationals and basically so
the number of points whose number of
bits are polynomial and log P I think I
have too many logs there or our Big O of
log P to the C for some for some
constant C which is related to the rank
of the curve and the point is is that
that's just a minuscule fraction of the
total number of points that you have oh
you know you know an e of F P so the
roughly P points there and so that's
they're just far too few points to even
have a decent chance of even writing
down the the points upstairs no matter
how you might lift them and so there
there's a lot of other details and in
fact I I analyzed you know the details
of this in my eighty-five paper so the
other advantage of elliptic curves is as
also was pointed out there are a lot of
them over FP of different sizes and so
basically this gives you a lot more
chances to deal with with other things
so basically crypto eighty-five and
afterwards I corresponding with a list
go and forming my ideas in the day I
finally convinced him with enough
details he told me that he just received
a letter from Neil Coblentz who I think
was in Moscow at the time sort of
outlining you know a similar thing so
this really was in a sense virtual sign
literally simultaneous and at crypto
that year the talk immediately preceding
mine was given by Nelson Stevens who was
Professor Birch's first student I think
on an exposition of Lester's factoring
method because again elliptic curves
were a completely new thing for the
crypto community so this was sort of a
mysterious thing so they they got a
double dose of elliptic curves
and after my talk Lenin Adelman Kevin
McKerlie asked that I give them an
impromptu exposition of the theory of
elliptic curves because they immediately
was struck by the fact that this there
was something to this and the next year
lenin ming de Wong asked that I give
them a similar talk about abelian
varieties which eventually led to their
random polynomial time algorithm for
prime ality proving using abelian
varieties and I correspond that
extensively with Ron Rivest PhD student
Burt cholesky when he was working on his
thesis about elliptic curves and he was
the first implement my algorithm for the
Veii pairing so here's Neil
what happened here okay and here's
Nelson Stephens then in 1969 and now and
here's Kevin McKerlie into
characteristic poses back in his hippy
days and back in his you know now now
that he's a big deal at Google now he
can be like Caesar I guess here's here's
Ming de Wong and Bert cholesky and there
were a few weak cases which I didn't
notice so Alfred Menezes Okamoto and
Vanstone well at least two of them are
here use the Veii pairing which I'll
talk about in just a second in a case
that I missed super singular curves more
generally what's called low embedding
degree and later Gerhard Frey and Hans
cured York used the tape pairing which
is closely related to the VAE pairing
with curves with P minus 1 points and
Nigel smart igor samaya of azusa - and
Kiamichi Araki for curves with p points
as we mentioned though here's benezia
Sakamoto and Vanstone miss Gerhard Frye
and Hans cured crook and Nigel smart and
prime allottee proving well Shafi
goldwasser who's here and her student
Joe Killian gave a polynomial size
certificate for private e of a positive
fraction of primes using elliptic curves
this was am I wrong about that you look
at the shopping that's that's the way I
understood it this was sort of one of
the big outstanding problems in
complexity is our it was known that you
could prove that a that P was prime
prime in random polynomial time
or if you assume various extended
Riemann hypothesis but the question is
was it was it done in polynomial time or
could you even give so basically this
was you know one of the first chinks in
in listen and later
a late Oliver at dinner fronts one Marin
generalized this to to all curves even
though this this actually depended on a
certain reasonable conjecture which
seems to be true and I guess Francois
will speak about this in more generality
and just even though this doesn't relate
to a lip to curves in 2002 Agrawal Kyle
and Saxena gave a deterministic
polynomial time algorithm not using
elliptic curves
well here's shafy and Joe and here's
oliver at the 69 conference and just a
few years ago
here's Francois and here's a K and s and
then I said you know so why compute the
Veii pairing so the VAP airing is
something that well given the name was
was first introduced by in its current
form by Andrey Vey
sometime in the mid 1940s and basically
it's it's a bilinear alternating gawa
equi variant non degenerate pairing
basically but if by linear in
alternating should be clear Galois aqua
variant really just means that if you
start with your inputs in a particular
field that your output ends up in that
field - and and basically it's used in a
lot of places on elliptic curves in
particular the the place algorithmically
where it's mostly used it's used in
two-cent calculations to find a basis of
the more del V group however in in that
case the end that you're computing with
is usually pretty small so it was never
seemed to be necessary to come up with a
really efficient algorithm to calculate
the thing since n was usually like - in
which case it was it was sort of obvious
what the answer was but what about when
n was big so I started thinking about
this so basically the other motivation
was in in scoffs paper
at the very end he put out out of a
challenge saying well we've given a
algorithm to calculate the number of
points on the elliptic curve over the
finite field but what about the group
structure the group structure as was
pointed out by professor Frey is always
a subgroup of Z mod n cross Z mod n and
so there's a real question of it's a
particular group you know what does this
structure look like so what happened in
December 1984 I gave a talk at IBM about
elliptic curve cryptography basically by
then I had sort of firmed up my ideas
and and professor Manuel Blum was in the
audience and challenged me because I
claimed that these should be more
difficult than ordinary discrete logs so
he said well why don't you give a
reduction and I thought well that's
reasonable question and so what would be
needed would be some easily computable
homomorphism from the multiplicative
group of the finite field to an elliptic
curve group and I thought about that and
the only thing that I knew that really
related those two was the Veii pairing
and well there was two questions could i
compute it quickly and then much to my
horror I found out it went the wrong way
it would seem to give a reduction in a
way that I didn't want but it turned out
you know so after an initial you know
scare I thought about it more
specifically and realized that it really
wasn't a it really didn't destroy
elliptic curve cryptography at all
because the degree of the extension
field that you'd have to compute in what
almost all the time have to be immense
in fact it would have to be almost as
big as P so in other words you would
actually have to write down points that
had P bits where P was say a you know as
a round size you know two to the hundred
and fiftieth so that clearly was
completely impossible
so I breathed a sigh of relief but then
I went back to saying well actually can
i compute this so the problem is is that
if you take the original definitions you
need to evaluate a function on a curve a
very high degree of essentially degree n
and and remember here n is going to be
roughly about the same size
so in theory you know the the classical
way you learn about it is in Riemann
rope you essentially reduces a problem
linear algebra and say all you quote all
you have to do is to find the
coefficients of this rational function
but the degree of the rational function
was a bad n so it's clear that that
approach was going nowhere so after
thinking about it for a while you could
see that you could use the process of
quickly computing a multiple of point to
give an algorithm which took place in
Big O of log P and I wrote up the paper
in in 85 and the paper was sort of
widely circulated and as an unpublished
manuscript and I actually submitted it
to the Fox conference with other things
but that was also rejected and an
expanded version I finally published in
in the Journal of cryptology so here was
Manuel Bloom and as far as the group
structure so the whole idea is an
abstract group it's known I mean it's
been known for a while that the group is
isomorphic to Zima DZ cross Z mod D easy
for some positive integers D and E and
so to find the group structure the
specific problem is given a over F P
find DNA and by by scoffs algorithm we
can find d squared e which is the order
of the group very quickly and the Veii
pairing lets us find D and E the whole
idea is the Veii pairing since it's non
degenerate if i give you a pair of
points the Veii pairing can quickly
determine whether or not the pair of
points generate the whole group and then
if it does it actually gets you D well
once you have D and you have d squared e
you also have have e so so that does it
now but one of the things is you need to
factor the GCD of P minus 1 and the
number of points on the curve and most
of the time that's going to be small but
in fact the latter problem was analyzed
by just a few years ago by Friedlander
Pomerance in spar Lenski who over here
and and so here's the thing so in 1984
Adi Shamir proposed something called
identity based encryption
and so this was just a a sort of paper
exercise at the time because he had no
idea how to implement this practically
and in 2000 Zhu gave the first steps
toward realizing this and he used my VAP
airing algorithm to do this and then
finally in the next year Bonin Franklin
gave the first funk you know fully
functional version also using the VAE
pairing and so now it turns out pairing
based cryptography is is now a really
burgeoning subfield actually says
hundreds of papers I should modify that
I think thousands of papers now I find
amazing so here's Adi Shamir and here's
Antoine Joo and here is Dan Bonilla
again and Matt Franklin and basically
they said it looked at cryptography is
now used in many standards and even the
NSA has the case for elliptic curve
cryptography and it's used in
BlackBerry's Windows Media Player stands
for biometric data on passports
I even we've told the US Federal
Aviation Administration had at least I
don't know if it ever come to pass was
going to use it in some sort of
collision avoidance system and most of
things I've completely lost track of
what's going on so basically I would say
it and with another cartoon from The New
Yorker and ask you know house how's
everything going and and no talk on
public key cryptography would be
complete without Alice and Bob and here
here's my version of Alice and Bob
where's Victor now it has
where there's where's Victor now in
there oh I don't know well nobody know
but nobody uses Victor and in you know
as the players I mean they've used Eve
they've used
I don't know Quentin for a quantum AI I
don't know you know they you know who
know I'm I'm anonymous verifier yes
that's true yes Victor the verifier all
right